before we get started a couple
logistical things
um homework zero is due tonight uh at 11
59. homework one has also been posted
now and it will be due on Wednesday next
week
we are also going to be posting a number
of resources for your project today uh
first we're going to be posting a number
of project ideas uh so if you're not
sure what to work on and you want some
ideas uh that should be pretty helpful
we're also going to post some example
projects from last year that could give
you a little bit of a flavor of the
kinds of things that have done people
have done for the class in the past all
right and then lastly um some people
mentioned that they love some help
connecting with others in the class that
have similar interests and so we're also
going to be posting a form that allows
you to kind of put down your interests
and whether or not you're looking for uh
project collaborators and we'll also
post the responses to that form today as
well and so it'll just help you connect
with people who have similar interests
this is an optional form uh it's more
just to help you find people if you're
looking for people to work with
um one other important note as well on
Logistics is that these days there are
some pretty fancy AI based code
completion tools like GitHub
um actually sorry that's the type of
copilot
um there's also a more recent one that's
even open source
um there aren't these are pretty new and
so there aren't a lot of kind of
standard course policies around using
these tools we'd like to say that it's
okay for you to use these kind of things
for the project but we'd say that it's
not okay for using it for the
assignments because the assignments
should you should really be able to
understand the code that you're writing
rather than trying to ask an AI to do
your homework for you
foreign
cool and then the last
um logistical item also as well is that
um your feedback is really important to
helping us help you to make sure the
class is a great experience for you and
so one thing that we're going to be
doing is called high resolution feedback
uh starting this week and it'll every
every week
a random subset of the class will be
getting a form a feedback form where you
can tell us how things are going
um and so forth and we'll use this to
improve the class
so not all of you will get this this
week um it will be a different subset
every week so that we're not putting a
ton of burden on you to fill out surveys
every single week but we can also still
get feedback throughout the course
great um and then lastly we've also
finalized the guest lectures for the end
of the course I'm really excited that
we'll have
um honey and Percy give Gus lectures
um Henny is at Google she does a lot of
really cool work on transfer learning
and understanding deep learning and
Percy is here at Stanford and he does a
lot of work on Foundation models not for
language processing
um and understanding emergency shot
learning
um so I'm excited to see those lectures
at the end of the course
great um so those are all the logistics
uh any any questions on all that so a
lot um all of this is on well these
things are on the course website um the
project resources will be posted on Ed
so
um yeah nothing is only here
awesome
um so
last lecture on Wednesday last week we
talked about multitask learning and we
defined what a task is as a set of data
generating distributions from which a
training set and a test set is sampled
the task also has a corresponding loss
function
um and we didn't explicitly cover this
but you can think of learning a task as
essentially taking as input a data set
and predicting a set of parameters
and those parameters would be the
parameters of your model we also talked
about multitask learning where we're
going to be training a neural network
that's conditioned on a description of
the task Z and is going to be making
predictions for inputs given that
descriptor of the task
we talked about how
basically the choice of conditioning on
Z in different ways affects how the
parameters are shared and different
design choices with respect to that
choice so if You observe negative
transfer you might consider sharing less
information and design new architectures
and designing ways to condition on Z
that affect that and likewise If You
observe overfitting you may want to try
sharing more and have more shared
parameters
um lastly we also talked about this
objective function for multitask
learning and how if you normalize your
labels then just adding up the losses
and optimizing like that is a great
choice but you may also want to choose
the task ratings in a way that affects
the prioritization of the tasks
great so that's a brief recap of
Wednesday's lecture
now the plan for today is we're going to
talk about transfer learning and the
problem formulation of that and then
we're going to actually start talking
about Metal learning and the problem
formulation and the way that we can
think about what meta learning actually
is
um this will actually get into the start
of homework one and the lecture on
Wednesday will kind of cover the rest of
the content that's needed for completing
homework one
um cool and then from there the cool
things that we'll cover today in terms
of learning goals are thinking about how
you can transfer things from one task to
another task
what does it mean for multiple tasks to
have some sort of shared structure which
is this somewhat nebulous notion that
we've been talking about for uh the last
week and also what is meta learning
awesome so let's get started by talking
about transfer learning
so um in lecture before we talked about
trying to solve multiple tasks at once
and in transfer learning things are a
little bit different
so in transfer learning our goal is
typically to solve
a particular Target task
after having previously solved a source
task or a set of source tasks
and the goal here is when we saw try to
solve the this target task we want to
transfer some of what was learned on
task a when trying to solve test feed
um and a common assumption here is that
typically you can't access the data from
task a when you're trying to solve task
B uh and so you basically want to
condense all your information and
knowledge about task a into some
parameters and then use that condensed
knowledge into when trying to address
task B
um now it's worth mentioning here that
transfer learning you can think of it as
a valid solution to multitask learning
because if you want to learn two tasks
then you could learn task one and then
transfer that to more effectively
learned task two that will give you a
solution to Task 1 and task two
um however because of this pretty common
assumption
UM multitask learning is not usually
thought of as a valid solution to
transfer learning because you can't
access the data for one of the tests
during the transfer process do you don't
access uh the data sets of the two tasks
at the same time
cool um so from there I have a question
for you
um so now that I've introduced these two
problem statements I'm curious
um if you have some ideas for what kinds
of problems
um you might run into where transfer
learning might make a lot of sense and
might make more sense than running
multitask learning
yeah so if your Source has a ton of data
then you don't want to have to keep this
around and like retrain on it when
you're solving test B you want to
condense that knowledge down and try to
transfer it so that's one setting where
you might want to use transfer learning
other scenarios
yeah
possibly normal
associated with
this house
yeah so if you don't have a lot of tasks
a lot of data for your Target task then
something like transfer learning might
make sense there I also think that
something like multitask learning could
probably also be applicable to that sort
of setting as well
um but it is a setting where transfer
learning is often is often used
uh yeah
[Music]
um
so then the translation can be part A
then location can be part B something
like that yeah
the scenario to use transfer learning
and all
it already might apply
um yeah
[Music]
exactly so if you've already learned
task a and the weights you can just
download from the internet maybe maybe
you haven't trained it yourself maybe
someone else did and they put their
weights on the internet then you don't
even actually have to solve task a you
can just take their weights take their
solution and use that for task B and so
that's another scenario where it's very
commonly used
um one more
they're playing this into an environment
where you don't have the capacity to
learn very much because you're there but
only then will you understand what it
has to be really is yeah exactly so you
might be in a scenario where you don't
um you don't know what what all the
tasks are up front you're in a scenario
where maybe you want to very quickly
adapt to a new task maybe you're trying
to adapt to
um like on a cell phone for example to a
particular user and that sort of
scenario is something like transfer
learning makes a lot of sense
cool um so those are like yeah lots of
really really great examples
um I had a couple examples that I put on
the slide the first was mentioned if you
have a really large Source data set you
don't want to have to retain this and
retrain on it with multitask learning
um and then the second case that I
mentioned uh is you may actually have a
scenario where you don't actually care
about solving both of the tasks
simultaneously uh
for example if ultimately your goal is
to kind of deploy a model on on
different people's phones you don't need
to have a model that works for every one
at the same time you just need to be
able to adapt the model to a user at any
particular point in time
foreign
have some information about
um the optimizer for example that maybe
you have stored but typically it's the
weights that you um have trained on
tasking
cool
um so now that we've talked about the
problem set up
uh we'll talk about fine tuning which is
basically the the go-to approach for for
transfer learning
and the way that fine-tuning works is
we'll take the weights that were trained
on task a
I'll denote this with Theta
and we will initialize a neural network
with those weights
and then run gradient descent on the
target task initialize at those weights
um and so if D train is the training
data for your new task then you'll
evaluate the gradient apply that
gradient uh at the network
initialize.theta this is showing just
one step of gradient descent but in
practice you would typically do this for
a number of gradient steps
and then the result of this process is
you'll get a set of parameters Phi that
are hopefully actually much better at
task B than if you were to randomly
initialize Theta
and in fact if you actually compare
using randomly initialized parameters
versus parameters pre-initialized with a
data set that is effective is useful for
the Target task we can see that we get
much better performance so in particular
here's an example where a neural network
is pre-trained on imagenet or it is
initialized randomly and the target data
set is these two data sets Pascal and
sun which are both image recognition
data sets and we see that we're able to
do remarkably better if we pre-trade on
imagenet compared to pre-training from
scratch
um on the order of like 16 to 17 percent
so this is really cool essentially what
this is doing is that it's taking all
the in like Rich information that exists
in the image.dataset leveraging that in
the context of uh transferring to these
new tasks
yeah
those
because
is
yeah so the question is um is there some
Criterion that could tell us
uh if transfer learning will work if it
will be helpful uh and in general kind
of similar to the multitask learning
scenario where it's difficult to tell if
training on two tests together will be
helpful um it's also very difficult to
just develop some Criterion and so in
general there are some kind of
General common wisdom for getting these
things to work well and in general for
example it's intuitively the tasks seem
related then
um then it can be a good choice but in
practice there isn't any any hard rule
that will tell us if it will work or not
um and so I guess I should say that
what I just said is dissatisfying to me
I think it'd be really awesome if we had
something that could tell us basically
whether this would work and
um we'll talk a little bit about some
recent research in some of the coming
slides but also investigating this sort
of thing for like a course project I
think
um could be quite interesting
yeah
all the layers yeah so in this case um
we're retraining the entire parameter
Vector um I guess I'll try to finish
this slide and then we can get to more
questions so
um
kind of related to like
um when will this work when will this
not work uh there's a number of choices
that you can select for the pre-trained
parameters
um things like imagenet classification
or models trained on a very large
language corpora are are common choices
in computer vision and NLP uh and in
general
if you can pre-train on on a diverse
data set that covers the kinds of data
that you'll be seeing during fine-tuning
this um
uh that's kind of generally a good
choice it doesn't even need to
necessarily cover the
um cover the distribution of what you'll
see at test time so for example an
image.classification people have found
that you actually get very general
purpose visual features from those and
you can take those visual features and
actually apply it to try to transfer
them to satellite images or try to
transfer them to Medical images and
those visual features are actually still
pretty useful even though those images
are out of distribution compared to what
image that images look like yeah
into it doesn't think that this is doing
something like creating a dictionary of
latent variables it's kind of
approximate dictionary and then fine
tuning is basically updating the
dictionary a little bit
yeah so the question is can we think of
this as
um the pre-training process is learning
a dictionary of latent variables and
then the fine-tuning process is
essentially
um
as updating the
um I guess I'm not fully sure what
fixing it towards a test exactly means I
mean the
I think that intuitively there's I guess
I think there's a lot of intuitive
explanations for what it may be doing
um one intuitive explanation is that
it's giving you good features so it's
giving you a good representation of
images for example it gives you a good
way to look at images or a good way to
read text
um so that's one explanation and once
you have once you kind of roughly know
how to see at a course level then that
makes it much easier to be able to
recognize other images
um and then a completely separate
explanation might be if you think about
from the standpoint of optimization if
you have this really complex
optimization landscape that is
non-convex then you could possibly think
of this as trying to put you in the
right Basin of that optimization
landscape and once you're in the right
Basin then if you run gradient descent
from that Basin you'll get to a better
solution than if you started off kind of
at a random spot in that optimization or
in that landscape
yeah all right so can this be related
it's the idea we have a simple model
learn that model
um and then initialize a more complex
model with ways to learn from the
simpler model there's this fall outside
that paradigm
so starting with a simple model and
going towards a more complex model so
um in general something like that I
would refer to as perhaps a form of
curriculum learning where you move from
kind of simpler tasks towards more and
more difficult tasks and things like
transfer learning can be applied to that
but that doesn't always have to be the
case you don't have to start with a
simple task and move do a call more
complex task in fact oftentimes you
actually move from a more complex task
to a simpler one like
image.classification is actually a
really really hard task to learn from
scratch and then you might move to
something that's a little bit simpler
like maybe you want to be able to
classify between like cats and dogs or
something like that
yeah
so if you have a large enough data set
then could it make sense to retain a
model from scratch or do you think that
fine-tuning would generally maybe still
provide somehow
so if you have a large enough data set
does pre-training make sense or can you
just train from scratch if you do have a
large data set then uh it's from a
performance standpoint it may be that
you can already do quite well training
from scratch on that large data set
there are still some potential benefits
one very obvious potential benefit is
that you may
um you may not need as much compute to
get to the solution so even if you have
a large data set if you can initialize
with the pre-trained model then you may
need many fewer gradient steps to and
many fewer compute Cycles to get to a
good Solution on that task compared to
if you were to train without any prior
knowledge
um
cool so
um kind of the common wisdom with these
pre-trained models is generally trying
to pre-trade on diverse data sets
um there's also some unsupervised
learning techniques that you can use for
pre-training uh and we'll cover those in
some of the upcoming lectures
[Music]
I mean is it is
yeah so the question was
um like generally well this may be part
of the answer too but um generally we
want the source tasks and Target tasks
to be similar to be related to one
another
um and you were asking if they need to
be related in terms of what task it is
versus what the data is and in reality
it's both it's both what the data looks
like and what you're trying to do with
that data
um that will affect how successful
transfer is
I'm going to move on a little bit to get
at least get to the rest of this slide
so all these are great questions
um now one of the things that was
mentioned before is that uh
one of the things that's really awesome
about transfer learning is it's not just
that you can do better by leveraging
this prior knowledge but that oftentimes
someone is already distilled that prior
knowledge into a model and put that
model on the internet uh so that you
don't even have to train on imagenet or
train on some some language corpora and
this actually significantly improves I
think the accessibility of things like
deep learning because it means that
anyone can download a model and use it
on on on their problem on their data set
as long as it's at least somewhat
sufficiently similar to these common
pre-trained models
cool
um now
in this example we this is kind of the I
think the one of the most common
versions of fine tuning where you
fine-tune the entire network
but in practice there's actually a lot
of different design choices that come up
when thinking about fine-tuning
and
a lot of these design choices kind of
revolve around
thinking about how to not destroy the
prior knowledge and prior information in
your model and balance that prior
knowledge with the knowledge from your
new data set
uh and in particular if you have a
neural network
um that uh
that has some layers
um
say for example you
um maybe you're trying to pre-trade on
imagenet and now you're trying to
fine-tune on a task like classifying
between cats and dogs
um or maybe I think cats and dogs are
probably in the image that data set so
we can maybe pick something more obscure
uh like I don't know classifying between
whiteboard markers and whiteboard
erasers or something like that
um in that case uh you have a network
pre-trained on imagenet
and um the output image has a thousand
classes and so the output layer is going
to be a thousand dimensional and your
target task has two possible labels one
for whiteboard markers and one for
whiteboard erasers
and so what you need to do in that case
is to
essentially kind of re-initialize the
last layer because you can't or at least
use some part of this um
you can't just directly use this last
thing you could either use two of the
classes and then throw away the last
half or just reinitialize a new network
on top of these features right here
now one thing that comes up is let's say
you re-initialize to instead have
um a last layer of two
a much smaller last layer
and these are now randomly initialized
weights whereas everything before this
is weights pre-trained on imagenet
now in that case if you back propagate
your gradients through the network
if this is a randomly initialized weight
Matrix then you're essentially going to
be multiplying your gradients by some
random numbers right here and then
applying those gradients to the rest of
the network and so then you're going to
be hitting these weight matrices with
numbers that have a lot more Randomness
in them and that might actually destroy
a lot of the really great information in
these layers
and so one common practice
um or there's a few different common
practices for people um that people do
one is to fine-tuned with a smaller
learning rate especially for the earlier
layers of the network because you don't
want these these features to be
destroyed by the gradients coming in
from the network
um smaller learning rate for earlier
layers sometimes also you might freeze
these earlier layers and only train the
latter parts of the network
or only train start by only training the
gradual part the last parts of the
network and gradually unfreeze from the
back of the network
um re-initialize lost layer which we
talked about
um so I guess these four things are are
fairly common design choices when fine
tuning
in terms of how to pick between those
design choices
um you can kind of search over those
design choices and Hyper parameters by
running cross-validation uh on your
target task
um and I guess the last thing worth
mentioning here is that the architecture
that you choose to fine-tune will also
affect the transfer performance and so
in particular residual networks which
have residual connections between layers
um these networks are often more
effective for to fine-tuning because you
get kind of a bit of a highway
um throughout the network and so you uh
it's easier easy great gradients to um
to all the layers rather than having to
um use the chain well rather than having
to kind of go one by one by layer
okay
um so now that we've gone over the
basics of fine-tuning are there
any more questions
yeah
complexity of that second transformation
let's say it's just you know cats versus
dogs maybe all you would need to do is
um a simpler change for that last player
right but if it's a really complicated
seconds then you may be the answer
yeah absolutely so
um the task the question was like if the
target task is simple versus complex
does that affect the um how you choose
to fine-tune the network and yeah if you
have a really simple task then you may
just only need to train this last layer
you may not even need to change the
features at all especially if that task
is very related to The Source task
whereas if it's very complex or very
different you may want to actually kind
of reinitialize more than one layer on
top of the features or kind of fine-tune
the entire network or something like
that
yeah
you don't have much
how do you prevent overfitting on that
data I deserve the principal way of
doing your reality yeah so if we have a
small amount of data how do we prevent
overfitting
um the most common thing to do is early
stopping which is also done in standard
machine learning which is instead of
fine-tuning this for a very long time
fine tune it for fewer gradient steps
watch your validation loss on your
target task and stop fine-tuning once
you reach a good solution you can also
fine-tune fewer layers as well so if you
fine-tune only the last layer then
you'll probably overfit less than if you
fine-tune the whole network
yeah
if you took like a free trade model like
you know for example and we're just fine
tune it on more exotic sort of or like
more specific instantiations of certain
objects or categories
um with the network still sort of show
um
understanding of what significant
distinctions between different classes
where like you know maybe two specific
instantiations of cat would be closer to
each other about the space that like you
know maybe a specific kind of dog
yeah so the question is if you fine-tune
on a more fine-grained classification
task like maybe classifying between
different species of birds or something
like that then would the features still
like would you get
um a good feature space for that task
such that like similar species of birds
are grouped together is that what you're
asking yeah so
um if you fine-tune only the last layer
of the network that won't affect the
features in any way and so you'll just
get the original image that features but
if you do fine tune the entire network
then that should also give you better
features for that Target task of course
if you have a really small Target task
then
the features
um you may not benefit well you may
overfit to that and so you may not get
good features of that or it may just be
beneficial not to fine-tune for very
long because you have a small data set
so it will depend a bit on your data set
size but if you fine-tune the whole
thing it will adjust the features and it
should learn a good
um a good space for for that a good few
study features
yeah
what's what's
function yeah yeah so the arrow on the
left it is kind of an assignment
operation so we're saying that we're
defining Theta we're defining Phi to be
um to be the right hand side of that you
can sort of think of it as an equal sign
although
um it's more directional
the foreign
yeah yeah so when you fine-tune
um if you fine-tune the whole network
well in general you should be using the
same architecture you can re-initialize
the last layer or re-initialize parts of
the network and change that part of the
architecture but in general especially
the first layers will need to have the
same architecture
yeah so if you have more layers then
you'll need to randomly initialize
though there isn't a great way to
initialize them performance
yeah all right can we all see is
transfer learning for multitasks uh but
just by separating the last few layers
you could also transfer to multiple
different Downstream tasks so you could
have like a mo like multiple heads for
example or you could pass in a z here
um one thing that's a little bit tricky
is if you want to pass in a z earlier in
the network or pass in some other input
earlier into the network that wasn't
there during pre-training then you need
to make sure that you kind of actually
update this layer during fine tuning
um but in general something like that is
definitely possible
cool was there one more question in the
back yeah
[Music]
so you're asking if you have the source
data available is that helpful during
the fine-tuning process
so
in general
so you could just do multitask learning
and train on both of the tasks and maybe
up weight the target task if you care
more about that
um that can be helpful if you don't want
to forget the source task
um it can be somewhat helpful to
regularize when trying to solve the
target task although in practice
it it depends a little bit on the
scenario and in practice actually just
often find oftentimes fine-tuning is
actually often better than keeping it
around
the other thing that you could do is you
could regularize towards the initial
parameters and that you can do actually
without the source data which is nice
and there are some works that have found
benefits for that in some scenarios
yeah so if you're working in some sort
of future is there has there ever been
has there been shown like any way to
sort of do a full-time shooting that
isn't this like explicitly worse than
linear evaluation
um
so you're asking in in the setting where
you have a very small amount of Target
data is it ever better to fine-tune the
entire network rather than just a small
thing on top
um all in two slides I'll get to
something that I think will somewhat
it won't fully address that but it will
show some scenarios where that are
better than just fine-tuning the last
layer
um
yeah
Okay so
I bought in general all the things on
this slide are I would refer all the
things on the bottom I would refer to as
kind of common wisdom around fine-tuning
uh and
it's also worth mentioning that this
common wisdom I think is changing uh and
it's not not fully set in stone and so
in particular on these next two slides I
want to cover uh two
uh two papers that uh maybe you might
consider as old by Machine learning
standpoint
um by Machine learning terms which is
that they both came out last week
and the first paper is a paper by some
folks
at CMU I believe
and they found that actually
that unsupervised or generally
pre-training doesn't necessarily need a
really diverse data set
specifically unsupervised pre-training
methods and so
um they found that if you randomly
initialize the network you get 72
success on the target task if you
pre-train on a on a book Corpus that's
much larger you get 81 so we do see a
benefit from pre-training here
but they also found that if you
pre-train with this unsupervised
objective
on the fine tuning data set
uh you actually get 80.96 success or
average accuracy which is actually very
close to the 81.3
and this I think breaks the common
wisdom because the common wisdom is that
typically we need a very diverse
pre-training data set and this suggests
that when you have an unsupervised
pre-training objective you may not
actually need a really diverse
pre-training objective or pre-training
data set you could possibly even just
pre-train on the target data set itself
um so this is kind of breaking the
common knowledge or the common wisdom
here
um if you have a supervised pre-training
task then this won't work out because
you like running supervised learning on
your fine-tuning data set and then
running fine tuning on your fine tuning
data set those are going to be the same
exact thing
um so this is I would expect to only
hold in the unsupervised pre-training
case
um but it's something that that breaks
the common wisdom and suggests that we
don't have everything figured out even
when it comes to fine-tuning yeah
yeah
this is only in stages versus can you
opt with this you're asking if this
would also hold in the multitask
ing
I think that they only ran experiments
in the pre-training and fine-tuning
phase
but
um you could read the paper for to check
and because it came out last week I
don't think anyone has built on it yet I
should mention that this has averaged
over a number of different
um they ran this this on a number of
different Target tasks this was all in
the NLP domain but there's actually
another paper that came out actually a
little bit before this that actually
showed a similar result in computer
vision tasks as well
um now the second paper um is actually a
paper that was co-authored by Yoon ho
and and others um you know is a TA in
the class uh he looks like this
and uh
I want to give a little bit of the kind
of the thought process behind the
research because I said I would try to
mention that a little bit in the course
and the thought process was that there's
a lot of scenarios where fine-tuning
only the last layer works really well
um so that's great
but is there anything actually like that
special about the last layer
um you can maybe think that it's
somewhat special and that it's kind of
closest to the labels in some sense but
in many ways it's also just like any
other layer in the neural network
and so his thought process as well
um maybe for kind of if we're trying to
fine tune to a pretty low level shift
maybe there are scenarios where the last
layer wouldn't work better but actually
maybe other layers in the network like
the first layer might actually work
better
um and he actually already had something
some experiments set up to run fine
tuning on image Corruptions and so he
pre-trained on the cfar c410 data set
which is an image classification data
set fine-tuned it on cfar 10c which is a
corrupted version of that data set where
there are small low-level image
Corruptions applied to the data and he
found that if you fine-tune the whole
network you get around 79.9 accuracy and
if you fine-tune only the first layer of
the network you get a higher accuracy on
the target task
um and then from there the thought
process was well okay if there's some
scenarios where the first layer Works
maybe there are scenarios where some
like only fine-tuning the middle layer
works
um and indeed there are some scenarios
where actually fine-tuning a middle
layer is actually better than
fine-tuning the whole network
um and so this is another example of
kind of breaking the common wisdom
because the common wisdom is typically
to fine-tune from the back of the
network but there are actually scenarios
where that's not the best option
of course these differences are are
still um they're kind of two to four
percent so full fine tuning still does
work pretty well in practice uh but it
says to us that we don't have a full
understanding of finding yeah
so the question is that different layers
have different numbers of parameters and
so it may be that like maybe that is
accounting for some of the differences
here maybe that has like a regularizing
effect or something like that
um in general I I cannot remember off
the top of my head the numbers and
parameters for each of these blocks
um
but the
um they did run experiments fairly
extensively on this they weren't
explicitly controlling for the number of
parameters but
um the results I do think suggested that
it had more to do with where in the
network you were fine-tuning compared to
um the number of parameters and I should
also mention that for full fine-tuning
um The Learning rate and
um
the early stopping were both determined
with cross-validation and so this is a
very this is like a pretty well tuned
Baseline
yeah
for some tax tax like imagenet data set
where we start off with uh like a color
image as the input and we now want to
task where we just have black and white
um it would make sense to just uh
retrain the first layer because it's
like a change in like the inputs but we
still want to do like the fundamentally
similar processing yeah
is there like any good intuition for how
for when we would choose like a middle
layer and which middle layer to choose
yeah so the question is um yeah like
what's what's some of the intuition here
especially with regard to the middle
layers
um and so in some of yunho's intuition
for trying this also was that
um you could sort of think of
so there's sort of a kind of a causal
process underlying kind of the process
of going from a label to generate an
image and you could sort of think of
neural networks as trying to reverse
that causal process uh where like when
you are for example trying to
um generate I think like this one you're
trying to predict vegetables for example
you may first go from
um the whether it's a vegetable or not
to something that's like what what type
of vegetable is it to like what is the
position of those vegetables and the
appearance of that vegetable and then
down to like what do pixels look like
for that kind of thing
um and when you change some part of that
causal process it if you think of that
as the entire chain it could be that
maybe if you change some change
something in the middle of that chain
then fine tuning the middle parts of the
network might be the best choice insofar
as neural networks might be kind of
reversing the causal process of image
generation
um so that that was some of our
intuition there
um but it's also something that is isn't
like still fully sorted out and I think
that one of the things that makes this
result interesting is that it is
different for different kinds of of
shifts between source and Target
yeah
yeah so in these cases it was also well
in this case the last layer was best but
um in the first two cases these were
also better than fine changes the last
layer
but of course
is it better than all the 15 different
types of Corruptions does it even
degrees
yeah so the question is is it um helpful
is the first layer good for all
different kinds of Corruptions
um
I
I believe it was better for the
um for
almost all of the Corruptions that we
tried
um I don't think I'm not sure if we
tried all 30 of them I think there's
there's a lot of them um but I think
that for at least for most of the ones
that we tried it was the best yeah
cool
um okay so now that we know that the
common wisdom is well the common wisdom
is okay but it's uh it's still something
that's kind of being developed
um I do want to give you somewhat of a
default because um if you if you do want
to actually use fine tuning in practice
I you don't want to have to navigate
this entire space of just design choices
and so
um
despite some of the results that we've
seen um I do think that if you want
something that is pretty reliable I
think something like first training the
last layer of the network and then
training the whole thing
um is is generally a really good place
to start and generally works well in
practice
um and the reason for that is exactly
what we talked about before where
um you don't want to you want to avoid
destroying your early features and so
you want to train these this last layer
the last set of layers first and then
fine-tuning the whole thing usually is
is helpful in practice
yeah how do you know when to stop
treating the last lawyer and then go
into functions
yeah so in terms of when to stop
training the last layer um typically
when you train the last layer you
typically don't overfit
because it's a pretty small number of
parameters
um and so you can mostly just look at
until you converge and then once you
roughly converge once you see the loss
function not going down anymore you can
start fine tuning the whole layer you
can also look at when the validation
loss starts to even starts to level out
as well
cool yeah
would this be applicable to online
learning
um
yeah I mean you could certainly kind of
do this repeatedly like re-initialize
the last layer and fine-tune that before
fine-tuning the whole thing and then
kind of do that repeatedly
yeah
um although I if you see are seeing kind
of a gradual shift in an online learning
setting you may just want to keep on
fine-tuning the whole network
cool
um and then the last thing that we'll
talk about with fine-tuning is that
um is looking at what fine-tuning
performance looks like when you have
varying amounts of Target task data and
this is just one example
um and so in particular what this is
looking at is the x-axis is the number
of training examples in your target data
set
and the y-axis is
um is the error the validation error
rate on that Target task
and so as we see as we have more Target
task data
um the better we do as we would expect
um the blue line is training from
scratch
um the green and orange line are
different
um different pre-trained models and one
thing we note is that if we have only a
hundred Target tasks data points uh the
performance isn't isn't nearly as good
as if we had a bit more than that
and in general these are this is still
doing pretty good like in this example
we only have like if we only have a
thousand examples we still do really
really well but it does start to get
much worse if we have only 100 examples
um and this is where things like metal
learning can can be useful
cool um so now let's with that in mind
let's transition to talking about Better
Learning so how do we get from transfer
learning to metal learning
um in transfer learning we talked about
how we'll initialize the model and hope
that initializing from there
helps on the target task
um the kind of key intuition behind meta
learning is instead of hoping that it
will help what if we explicitly optimize
for transferability
and what I mean by that is if we have
not just one source task but a set of
source tasks
can be optimized for the ability to
quickly learn these tasks
such that we can learn new tasks quickly
as well
so if we learn how to
quickly learn a set of tasks already
that means that we should be able to
also learn new tasks quickly
and so you could also think of this as
if we think about learning as going from
a data set to a set of parameters
um and we want to be able to
learn quickly then we could think about
essentially trying to optimize for this
function
so that we can learn well even with
small data sets or even when we have a
small compute budget
so that's the intuition behind meta
learning
there's two different ways to view meta
learning algorithms
the first is more of a mechanistic view
and the second is more of a
probabilistic view related to the idea
of kind of optimizing that learning
process you can the mechanistic view is
that
um
you can think about a deep neural
network that takes his input a data set
and makes predictions for new data
points and you just want to optimize
this deep neural network using this kind
of form of metadata set
and optimize it over those tasks so that
if you give it a data set for a new task
it can give you parameters for that new
task
so that's the more mechanistic view
that's how you might kind of implement
one of these algorithms
the more probabilistic view is if we
have a set of source tasks
we could try to extract the shared
knowledge the shared structure from
those tasks in a way that allows us to
efficiently learn new tasks
and so then we have a new task we'll try
to use that prior knowledge to infer the
parameters for the Target task
so
um with these two views in mind uh I
want to try to
first kind of talk a little bit about
this probabilistic view which will help
us think about what it means for tasks
to share a structure and then we'll go
back to the mechanistic view
um cool so let's start with the
probabilistic view think about what uh
what Bays would think of meta learning
and for this it'd be helpful to go
through the graphical model so
um
to start off how many of you
are familiar with Bayesian networks or
or equivalently directed graphical
models raise your head
okay and how many of you are not
familiar with Bayesian networks or
directed graphical models
okay it's about 50 50.
um
so
basenets or graphical models are covered
they're covered in cs109
um
and so for people who did undergrad at
Stanford you probably have learned about
them although you may be a little bit
Rusty so we'll we'll kind of walk
through it a little bit
so
um
in the
I don't know if I think I'll call them
directed graph or graphical models in
general
um they're often called phase Nets as
well so in graphical models um random
variables are denoted with circles
so if we have a random variable X we put
X in a circle
um we may also have a separate random
variable y
um so these are just two different
random variables
and dependencies between random
variables are represented with arrows
and so for example if you have a a
distribution P of Y give it X
um this Arrow kind of represents this
dependency
and if
for example this is equal to
P of Y
that means that there is actually no
real dependency on X and so you wouldn't
draw an arrow here
so actually I'll leave that up so now
um the other thing about Bayes nuts is
that it tells you a little bit you can
read off kind of whether or not two
variables are independent
and so if you have
maybe you have a Bayesian Network
that looks something like this
um you can
look at this and figure out if two
variables are independent so for example
and a and Y are not independent from
each other because they have a line that
connects them
and a and b are actually also not
independent because they have a path
that kind of goes from A to B
so any set of variables that have a path
between them are not independent they
have some dependency whereas if there's
no path between them then those two
random variables are independent so for
example A and D are independent from one
another
cool um so that's a kind of a very
basically all you need to know about
graphical models
um at least for now
so um now I want to draw
um what I'll call is the graphical model
for single test learning
so in particular
say we have
some parameters
some labels
and some
some inputs then we could think of
having a graphical model of basically to
predict why it's going to be a function
of X and our parameters because uh you
can we have this kind of relationship of
f of Y given
um
given X and and five
so you can think of this as a graphical
model for
um
for single task learning I should also
note that
if you are thinking about causality
sometimes people might this Arrow or the
kind of relationship between X and Y uh
you could possibly like flip these
arrows um to be in different directions
uh but for the standpoint of this
lecture it'll be helpful to consider
this direction and we won't really be
considering things from the kind of
causality standpoint
um cool and you can think of Phi is
essentially the parameters of of Y given
X and these are the parameters that
we're going to be trying to infer in
machine learning or in single test
learning
foreign
there's one more thing that's helpful to
know about graphical models um and this
actually may not have been covered in in
um which is what's referred to as plate
notation
um and in particular if you have
multiple data points so say this is just
one input and one output
then it'd be nice to have something that
could
kind of denote the entire data set not
just one input and one output and so
that's called plate notation which is
that instead of drawing all the
different data points which would take
me a long time we'll instead kind of
draw a plate
around
here we'll have an eye here that will
denote that this plate is over I and
this means that basically this makes
copies of everything inside the plate
indexed by I
cool any any questions on on this
graphical model does this make sense
cool so now if we get into multitask
learning and think about the graphical
model there
um first that means that we're going to
have multiple tasks and so we're going
to have
um well it can index the tasks by J
and then we will have another plate
around here
which will just mean that we have
multiple tasks that go that are indexed
by J so Phi J is the parameters for Task
1 task two task three and so forth
and
these parameters have some shared
structure and in particular
there's some dependency on these
parameters
um
by Theta
why does y only depend on Phi so y
depends on both Phi and X so there's an
arrow from Phi to Y and X to y
'all
why existence
why is our
um
this work is a little bit messy I guess
why so why is the label and Phi is the
true parameters
yeah
so you can think of um I is over data
points J is over tasks uh and so this
means that for every task there is
another there's a set of data points
yeah
yeah might not be true right because if
you want to be like the same way yeah so
you may actually have something where
like X is outside of this plate it's
it's more like
um actually no so yeah that it may not
be true
um and so
this is the more General case where
they're different but in in practice and
I'm actually not sure how I would draw
it if I were to it's a little bit tricky
to draw yeah
so Theta Theta is kind of an interesting
thing so Theta is um
you can think of theta as this shared
information between the tasks and it's
only the share only the stuff that's
shared between the tasks
and um I use the word latent here
because latent means unobserved so
um in particular the data points
um X and Y are observed and so in
graphical models if you shade something
in which is a little hard to do on
whiteboards that means that they're
observed whereas we don't observe the
true parameters and we don't observe
what the shared structure is
and so it's worth mentioning that if
there is if there is no dependency here
then that means the tasks don't share
any structure
whereas if there is some dependency on
the shared structure then they um they
do actually have some some shared
information between them
um I'm just using this to denote the the
kind of individual data points in our
trading data set
foreign
good question
um
yeah so you could alternatively think of
X and Y as the
um
as the random variable like the random
variable X and the random variable y uh
and in that case you wouldn't you
wouldn't need the plate here you would
still need this this plate but you
wouldn't need this button yeah
yeah
um so is this like the equivalent of a
distributed model since you're taking X
like the X divisors like a given and
like a more General case is there also
something else like some noise
effectively exercises
yeah so there could be cases where
there's other things that affect X and
other things that affect y
um I'm leaving those out for Simplicity
but
um for example y may not be perfectly
like there could be some noise that
affects y if you have label noise for
example
um there could be other things that
affect X
um but yeah for Simplicity I'm leaving
those out
cool
um so
the um here I just kind of Drew this
like
um for the the training data points um
it's helpful in some cases to actually
write it out in a way that separately
represents the test data points
um and
I mentioned that because
um the test data points are not fully
observed
um the labels are not fully observed if
you have a set of training tasks and you
can observe the labels for the training
tasks
um but we'll we'll go into that more in
a future lecture
um but now let's get into a little bit
about Theta so
um if you condition on the shared
information on Theta
then it's worth noting that
um
the task parameters uh well so first the
task parameters are not independent
right now because there's a kind of a
path between them
but if you condition on Theta the task
parameters become independent
um and so what that means is that if you
condition on Theta you'll actually have
a lower entropy distribution over your
your task specific parameters Phi I
compared to if compared to just your
kind of Prior over 5i
and so what that means is that um well
actually no maybe I'll ask you this so
um
so if you can identify if you know the
shared structure if you can identify the
shared structure Theta
then when should learning Phi I be
faster than if you didn't know that
shared structure
people have thoughts
foreign
I could also walk through the slide a
little bit again so I guess
um the first step is that if we
condition on on the on this
variable then
um these become independent
um and if you have information about
Theta that uh that lowers your entropy
estimate of Phi because the
um
essentially the um you can kind of
narrow down what the value of Phi is
once you have information about Theta
and so from there
[Music]
um
if we can identify information about
Theta then
with this dependency learning Phi should
be faster because we have fewer bits to
to uncover from our trading data points
yeah as long as you really understand
the relationship between data
yeah so if if you have if you have
information about Theta and this
dependency exists and you understand
that dependency then learning Phi should
be faster than if you didn't have that
information
exactly
um basically you need fewer less
information about the data points
um to infer five once you have
information about Theta
um one other thought exercise
um
that builds on this a little bit more
is um
so we talked about how if you have
information about data that tells us
that lowers our entropy that gives us
more information about Phi
now what if the entropy of Phi given
Theta is zero
yeah
[Music]
so if if basically if it's if
um your entropy goes to zero then you
actually fully notify you like
um you have full information about Phi
and at that point you can actually just
fully solve the tasks
um yeah and that means that you don't
even need any additional data to solve
the task
cool
um so in general I think that this this
sort of Bayesian perspective
um
I think is a useful framework for
thinking about what it means for some
tasks to share a structure uh and
specifically in the kind of the form of
of this variable here and you can think
about these kind of different
mathematical relations
um
as when we might expect
um basically how much shared structure
is versus how much data you need to
learn a given task
cool um two other exercises
um or well one exercise with two
examples so
um
say that we have a set of sinusoid tasks
so uh task one is
um
a sinusoid with uh
an amplitude of like five and a kind of
a phase of Pi and then maybe task two is
an amplitude of one and a phase of pi
over two or something like that
um and all of your tasks have different
amplitudes in different phases
then in that scenario what information
does does Theta contain
um
not quite so so the amplitude and phase
this is this is for top one this is for
task two the question is what is kind of
what is Theta what is the shared
structure between them
uh yeah
yeah exactly so everything but the
amplitude and phase so it kind of is
um
corresponds to the family of sinusoid
functions
um that once we have that shared
structure we just need to infer these
two values using our data set
um one more example so say that we
um our tasks are machine translation
uh and our goal is to translate between
two languages and one task is to
translate from French to English and
other tasks is to translate from
Japanese to Spanish or something like
that
in this case what is what does Theta
correspond to
yeah
any privileges so you're saying it's
possible translation between any pair of
languages
any family of two languages
um so basically basically would allow
you like you're saying that the shared
structure is kind of a universal
translator
yeah that's that's close although not
not quite
yeah
Universal languages yeah so you're
saying things like adverbs and verbs and
stuff like that yeah so this is I guess
both of these are like mostly right
um it's basically going to be everything
um and I guess I mean sort of the first
one too it's um basically tells us
information about
um the family of all language pairs
although it shouldn't contain all of the
information needed to translate between
um one pair of languages because
um well ideally it shouldn't be the
things that are only the things that are
shared and not the things that are
needed to to actually solve the task
languages are so diverse yeah so this
will be um
will be like relatively small it won't
include things like vocabulary of a
given model
um but it will contain things like
adverbs and like like the kind of
grammatical structure that you often see
in in languages
um
right so the specifics of like what like
what order do you put do you put the
adjective before the noun or after the
noun those sorts of specifics won't be
contained in Theta um but the general
notion of those things
um is somewhat shared this is also sort
of a hard question because it's
something that's rather vague and hard
to put into words yeah
yeah so the question was um like in
practice what is like like this data
correspond to like earlier layers or
like what is this Theta thing
um so here we're really like just
thinking conceptually
um
in practice uh this can it can
correspond to a number of different
things I chose the notation Theta and
um I chose the notation Theta in part
because one thing it can represent is
the initialization of fine tuning um you
can think of it as kind of the
initialization is kind of prior
knowledge or kind of source shared
structure
um but we'll see this much more
concretely when we get to the lecture on
Bayesian meta learning
yeah
still I referring to us
oh and is a meddling task and a task
equivalent or
not oh
um yeah so this this graphical model
will be the same for both multitask
learning and metal learning yeah
yeah anytime you it's basically the
graphical model for a set of tasks it
doesn't really cover and both multitask
learning and metal learning consider a
set of tasks
foreign
yeah so this last part
um so what does entropy of zero mean so
entropy of zero means that you
um
your distribution over Phi is basically
just
um deterministic it just has a single
value whereas if we had a non-zero
entropy that would mean that we have
some uncertainty around Phi our
distribution would be a wider
distribution and so when the entropy is
zero that means that we know exactly
there's only one value that that the
distribution covers there's only one
value that the random variable can take
on and so in this case when the entropy
of Phi given Theta is zero that means
that uh Phi can only take on one value
once we have the information in Theta
and that means that we kind of have
already that means that once we have
this information we can fully recover
um the parameters for all of our tasks
[Music]
populate the relationships between your
clients yeah so you can think of meta
learning as basically trying to infer
Theta so try to maximize for the ability
to learn a new task and when we have a
well ideally if we like it'd be nice if
we could just get Phi directly but if
we're trying to optimize for the ability
to learn a new task
um given a set of tasks the best that we
could do is recover Theta and once we
have Theta then that will allow us to
learn new tasks from that distribution
um more quickly
yeah
so
Yeah so basically um yeah you can think
of metal learning as trying to infer
infer Theta
yeah so you can think of metal learning
as trying to learn inductive biases or
trying to learn like structure and
there's separately choices of structure
that we build in ourselves as humans and
those can be represented
um
I guess the
the way that I might represent that is
by having some
uh some other variable here which is
like the human built-in inductive bias
and that maybe also has some prior over
like maybe we have we have some guess
that what Phi is
um and that's gonna this will kind of
denote that sort of guess and so yeah
something like that
yeah
I can imagine a situation where uh we're
we're training we're just like three
main tasks two of the tasks are very
similar to each other the third one is
like completely different so there's
like so there's no shared knowledge
that's Universal across all tasks but
still like
oh so so in in this case with five one
and five two still be like
dependent on each other but like
yeah
um so you're saying that in the case so
this is this isn't a problem with two
tasks you're saying in the case of three
tasks
um
there may be scenarios where
the baby scenarios were
[Music]
um
the
like there's a lot of shared structure
between two of the tasks less trade
structure between the third and then
kind of the least common denominator is
pretty small in that case and so then
when you condition on that the first two
tasks are not independent
yeah so I think that when you
um
yeah I think the cases like that end up
getting more complicated uh I think it's
the cleanest to think about in the case
with two tasks and when you have more
than two tasks
um
yeah it's a yeah a little bit more
complicated to think about
um happy to discuss that more like an
office Outreach
cool we have about five more minutes
um
trying to think about
so let's talk a little bit about the
mechanistic view
um and yeah we won't we may not quite
finish it but we're going to start we're
gonna talk a lot more about my learning
next lecture so
um it's okay if we don't finish so
um
we covered this probabilistic view which
is trying which is better learning as
basically trying to recover this chart
structure recover this data
um for the rest of the lecture we're
going to talk a little bit about the
mechanistic view
and Bays will come back later in the the
Bayesian metal learning lecture
cool so
um
from the standpoint of the mechanistic
view say our goal is to classify images
and we have in this case a really tiny
data set of five examples
and our goal is to take this training
data set and classify new examples so
kind of going back to our conceptual
view these are going to be kind of
examples for a new task for X and Y
no
um if we want to solve this task from
scratch it won't work very well and so
we want to have we want to leverage
previous information
and specifically if we have data from
other tasks then we should be able to
use that to help us solve this few shot
classification problem
and in particular what we can do is we
can take data from other image classes
and construct them into tasks each with
their own train set and test set
and so in particular here might be one
task where instead of classifying things
like lions and dogs and Bulls our task
is to classify like birds pianos
mushrooms and a different breed of dawn
or in this case we can construct a
different task with its own training set
and test that where our goal is to
classify between Landscapes gymnasts and
carousels for example
um and so on and so forth and what we
can do is we can construct all of these
different tasks ideally lots of
different tasks
uh these will be used these will be
using a set of training image classes
and we want to construct them in a way
that allows us to learn how to quickly
learn each of these tasks such that when
we're given examples of New Image
classes we can also learn a classifier
for that task
so you can think of this top process as
The Meta training process where we are
kind of learning how to learn these
tasks and the the bottom part as the
medding test meta testing part where
we're trying to learn a new task
this is an example with image
classification where all the tasks are
these uh these image classification
problems but you can replace image
classification with really any other
kind of machine learning task so it
doesn't have to be an image task it
could be a regression task it could be a
language generation task it could be
trying to learn a skill
um really any of the kind of tasks that
we saw before multitask learning could
also be used to replace the tasks here
um now
the um then kind of more formally the
goal of meta learning is to try to given
data from a set of tasks try to solve a
new test task more quickly more
proficiently or more stably
um oftentimes in a lot of the use cases
we'll see in this course are to try to
learn more quickly with fewer examples
but in principle all these ideas could
also be trying to optimize for other
aspects of the learning process like um
performance and the stability of the
learning process
um now one really key assumption here
is that we're we have a set of training
tasks
we're going to assume that our test task
is drawn from the same distribution as
our training tasks
and so
um in particular we'll have some broader
distribution over tasks it can be a
little bit hard to think about what a
task distribution is but there is some
broader distribution over those tasks
and we need to assume that the training
tasks and the test tasks are both drawn
from that distribution such that when
we're given enough samples of our
training tasks we can naturally expect
to generalize and learn a new test task
from that distribution
so this is analogous to the standard
assumption in machine learning where we
assume that our train set and our tests
that are drawn from the same data
distribution
um and like before we we probably want
these tasks to share structure
um if this task distribution is a
completely random distribution then we
won't expect to be able to learn a new
task because these tasks are drawn
completely from random
um cool and then the task can compare to
a number of can actually correspond to a
number of different things you can see
basically correspond to the same kind of
tasks that we saw in multitask learning
and one example that we'll see in
homework one is uh to recognize
handwritten digits from different
languages where we might want to be able
to recognize new digits that we haven't
seen before
um I'll skip through this for the sake
of time
um and I think I'll skip the terminology
too I think that we can cover the
terminology
um in um in Wednesday's lecture
cool um so to start to recap
um in this lecture we talked about
transfer learning and meta learning we
only got to the very beginning of meta
learning but in transfer learning the
goal was to solve a Target task after
having solved a source task
and you can think of metal learning as a
subset of the transfer learning problem
where we have a set of source tasks and
we want to transfer information from
that to a new test task and so really
it's basically the same problem except
we're going to assume that we have not
just one source task but multiple Source
tasks
um generally in both of these cases it's
fairly impractical to access data from
The Source tasks
um and in all of these settings we want
to have some sort of shared structure
um and then we'll skip some of these two
slides
um yeah and then to kind of provide a
recap Beyond just the problem settings
um today we talked about
transferring via fine tuning by
initializing and then optimizing on the
target task and trying to be careful not
to destroy the features that were
initialized in the network by using a
smaller learning rate or by trading the
last layer first
we talked about this graphical model
which can give us some conceptual
intuition for what it means for tasks to
share structure by having this
statistical dependence on this shared
latent information
um and then lastly we talked about how
metal learning is aiming to try to
actually infer what this shared
structure is and use it to learn tasks
more quickly
um cool
um so that covers the plan for today
um in terms of the next lectures the
next five lectures will be on really
core methods for meta learning and
unsupervised pre-training and these will
also be covered in homeworks one two and
three
um and then yeah lastly a couple
reminders homework zero is due tonight
so make sure you you get that in